do
do
do
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
hi everyone what's up welcome to another
daily premonition 2 stream i'm very
excited uh
sorry if you got a bunch of
notifications there
i was having trouble getting youtube to
update
the the title it was like you're playing
four guys and i was like i'm definitely
not
uh because i'm having issues with
youtube events right now so
that's that but let's do it i'm
really excited to play this game again
um though i am also a little bit lost
because it's been a while
so i'm pretty sure the last thing that
happened was that
again i always have to pre-face whenever
i talk about this game what i'm about to
say is 100 true
i'm not making this up so
if i remember correctly the man who
spoke to me
in the painting appeared again at
the uh jail cell
where i had just discovered that the
woman who caused the murder that i was
investigating
uh was murdered herself so we found her
we tried to leave um the mysterious man
showed up in the wall and spoke to me
and told me something that was related
to a church
so i tried to go to the church to talk
to the pastor who was like
in some way involved with this whole
murder conspiracy even though we already
locked up
the person who was definitely the
murderer there's another person
who like maybe orchestrated it we're
trying to figure that out
um and when i went to talk to the pastor
they were like i need you to get me some
beans
but it didn't happen that way
it happened in a way that was more along
the lines of like
he was like in the name of the lord
we need to get beans um
as well as like a couple of other things
so
that's pretty much where we're at i
think um
it was like beans and spinach and maybe
something else um and he refused to help
me until i just go and get him food i
don't think he said anything else does
this game have like a quest list oh
yeah you could do [ __ ] wall-e's
because there's a skateboard mechanic
oh jeez pay a visit to chuck the man who
first discovered lisa's body okay so
elise is the
the girl who died uh initially
right we've got more than one death now
this is a game about a detective
just fyi okay
the lord hungers is the name of the
quest that i'm going
after so one of these things is that i
need to buy a can of spam at melvin's
the lord hungers part two again this is
the main quest
real didn't make any of it up is that i
need to order red beans and rice at
alexis diner and lane i think i tried to
do that and they were closed
and then the lord hunger's part three is
by can't spit
why would the canned spinach be at
azulli frida
either because azulee frida is
the part of this game where you get like
the voodoo dolls and [ __ ]
it doesn't make any sense it doesn't
make any sense
um okay but let's try and get one of
these i guess i don't know um
i don't remember how to do anything
really at all
no okay that's and that's going to
confuse the [ __ ] out of me because i
haven't used this pro controller in so
long that i'm going to keep
pressing xbox buttons okay let's just go
to
our frame rates ladies and gentlemen you
remember
this oh oh what a you know
sometimes you just gotta spend time on
your friday night
playing a beautiful video game like
okay abzu all right uh
ahri in the blind forest nice try
no man's sky have you seen this [ __ ]
[Music]
this beautiful video again thank you
senior busy man
um i guess the canned spinach could have
magical properties
that is fair um yeah oh my god they
patched it i did have to download the
update
before logging on today um so
the frame rate has been obviously
improved
i mean i think this is [ __ ] buttery
smooth i don't know what y'all talk
about this is the smoothest
video game i've ever seen in my entire
life wait so this is closed right no it
should be open
it's gonna be just fine let's get off
the watch [ __ ] i pressed x
this is gonna suck it's gonna take me
forever to get used to every controller
again
okay what do you oh yeah
oh yeah she follows me around everywhere
and this happens if you run away
all right like if no she she clips on
things but sometimes she teleports
um she's like basically my assistant her
dad is my favorite character
okay i need to get beans
oh hello my sister's watching hi sarah
she's drunk excellent that is a good
state to be in
while watching this ridiculous [ __ ]
video game
uh remy i'm glad you asked this is
better
than the new tony hawk game so
um infinitely superior
[Music]
uh but yes it's it is uh tony hawk pro
skater 12.
oh the air okay what do i need from you
i think i need like rice and beans maybe
x oh coming right up
rice rice and beans rice and isn't that
what i need from you
it's not shrimp and grits
hey i'll just take a step back here you
what do i need to buy from this woman
the lord hungers i'm there order red
beans and rice did i just not see it
maybe i need to talk to her no
that's right she told me that i had to
find a special ingredient
[Music]
maybe i [ __ ] what do you mean
by find that ingredient like wouldn't it
be tight
if you could give me a recap of what the
quest is
is there anything in here that says any
i feel like she maybe needed me to go
find beans
[Music]
what why is
this a side quest that exists
what is this
it gather one rice at okay that is it
i need to find the sugar cane plantation
[ __ ] hell all right
that's maybe here it's here
all right waypoint yes and i can
i could fast travel but like why would
you you know
when you could explore an open world
this beautiful
why would you ever fast travel i mean
it just doesn't make sense it goes to
tsushima garbage video game have you
seen this
okay all right okay this is clearly the
superior video game
uh in all technical aspects especially
up in world traversal
i mean you're kidding yourself if you
think otherwise let's be [ __ ] real
ah this this is uh every time i panic
because i worry that it's
um broken um oh for those asking why i'm
shadow band on twitch
it's because i streamed uh music and
they shadow banned me it's a bummer
but it's fun it's whatever hopefully it
fixes itself eventually you know
corey does wish he could make a game
this good not gonna happen though
not gonna happen
who is he getting
corey told me on twitter that he's
against putting fishing minigames in
games
deadly premonition has a bowling mini
game
a rock skipping mini game um
i mean drones you know the big three
that's what i've been asking for in
video games my whole life so
really [ __ ] wrong button again why is
on the left
on a nintendo controller it's [ __ ]
rude that they've done this to me but
it's fine
let's go let's go
more polygons in his shoes than all of
ghost you're right dude
you talk about the trees and goes to
tsushima you know what i think video
games need more of
pop in textures look at that look at it
come in i could write a review
about how a pop in texture is it look
let's just we just fade towards this
tree here
delightful surprise you never know
exactly what it's going to look like
you know you kind of got to wait a
little bit you're like oh what's the
texture of this tree going to be is it
going to be like the one directly before
it or is it maybe going to be a little
bit different i don't know
until i pop right next to it feature not
a
feature not a button all right keep
going
thank you raghav what do you mean before
guys not update does it still say i'm
playing full
guys on youtube it's super annoying i
don't know what's going on with that
[ __ ] live system right now but it
does that
um okay do i need to cross the river i
think that's where i'm going
oh i should activate that real quick no
[ __ ] wrong button again
stupid [ __ ] okay
she's [ __ ] child spawning behind you
is why did you [ __ ] you just [ __ ]
witch
i don't trust you at all
all right let's go
i feel like i've been to this plant
isn't this plantation where i did like
the last main quest
i feel like it might be this seems
suspicious
i don't know the youtube title is
updated yeah
yeah is the is the description updated i
don't [ __ ] know
anyway oh i was pressing the wrong
button again
it's fine we can we can skateboard on
cross
don't worry about it
oh okay
[Music]
yeah yeah so for anyone who's just
joining us for some reason
i i'm calling them drones but this is a
ufo
um
i [ __ ] love this video game there are
ufos in the town
that have loot i don't what's your
problem i don't understand what you're
confused about it's
it makes perfect sense oh there it goes
right into the ground
is it rice it's a low quality plate i
was hoping to get one of those
i was really anchoring for that ah thank
you senor busy man i appreciate that
how many hours from funhouse intro are
we so um i started this this gameplay
directly after the the fun house intro
video so immediately afterwards
um this is probably like five hours
after the intro
basically evan johnson said so why do
you love the absurdity of this so much
what turns a bad into a great
um my humor is uh the things that make
me like cry from laughter are things
that are absurd
um if any of you know me from funhouse
you will have seen
the infamous adam fox chew
uh crying video um that's basically what
are you [ __ ] doing
they try to make him sway a little bit
but he's sort of just
just hanging out in you yep anyway
uh yeah i laugh at things that are that
uh that are so upset that they don't
make sense that's what really really
cracks me up
why is this sparkly are any of you
rice though
no like i'm here for the side is there a
way to like make it my active quest
it's this one gather one rice at sugar
cane plant that's where i am
active quest question mark no i guess we
just explore the area i don't want to go
back in there again
what is that black dot do you suppose
that black square over there
i'm worried that if i go in it'll it'll
suck but let's
give it a shot oh uh king of goldfish
beans for god's in the title uh
was because that's what i'm pretty sure
well while i was making the title i was
pretty sure my active quest was
um it is i do have to get beans for god
that's the quest so you don't want to go
back in there right because this is
where that like
i don't want to do this i just want a
grain of rice
i don't want to go back to the other
place so uh yeah this detective video
game
um in case i forgot to mention excuse me
also has like a different universe
um don't worry about it
i left my window open i'm gonna go close
that real quick because i can hear
people talking so that means they might
be able to hear me and it might be
annoying the [ __ ] out of them give me a
second
let me go
hi i'm back
my [ __ ] grain on rice i literally
have to
it's fine it's fine it's fine this video
game is incredible
i'm not mad about it i literally have to
find a single grain of rice
um okay
yep cool don't know where it's gonna be
it doesn't say well it could be more
than one grain i suppose but
i'm still [ __ ] literally at a
plantation looking for rice in a
bathroom so
why is anyone here
also there should be music in here i
appreciate the vibes
this is the cyberpunk secret lab chat
yeah
it's good i'm a fan it's good stuff
all right another loading screen
uh very glad that i loaded in to do that
it's important stuff
see goes to tsushima why why
when you could have this you know
okay don't question it
are you gonna what it did crash one time
come on buddy come on little guy
okay there you go proud of you you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] did it look at you
being a video game
so where am i supposed to find this rice
though
this guy is freaking me out is it this
why can i open this again there's just
always a low quality plate in there
ah i just accidentally got up skirt on a
little girl i didn't mean to do that at
all
excuse me so do you have rice excuse me
[ __ ] [ __ ] how about you dude
do you have rice
if i go to the map right we can press a
i am definitely at the right i'm just
gonna have to run through the fields
like what do you [ __ ] want me to do
here
oh my god this thing looks like it would
contain rice does it have a door
oh there's a run button as well i forgot
what it is is it
uh if for some reason it's
why is it oh that's such a weird okay
whatever it's fine
perfect video game yeah give me that
sugarcane ear
what is a sugarcane ear
okay well where's rice
i don't know
oh you can't walk through these that's
interesting
i did not expect that to be a thing
they're all uh yep
but that limits the rice options
significantly
stop teleporting you weird [ __ ] maybe
you'll tell me where rice is though
by the way patty what do you usually do
what i was off though
is this an interrogation always often
right i just figured that since we're
working together now
it'd be a good idea to learn a little
more about you should an adult male like
you really be asking a little girl this
kind of question
i feel like i heard a story about this
sort of thing on the news once
there's a time and a place for
everything you know exactly who i am
and i've also introduced myself to your
father besides
you're the one who said you wanted to
come with me i was just kidding
jeez you're an fbi special agent why
would i ever need to worry
you shouldn't automatically trust
someone just because they're an fbi
classic actually man
more than one's personality are
completely separate things
for example one special agent may fall
spiritually in love with a genius
criminal who enjoys the taste of human
flesh
that's hannibal you pulled that straight
out of a movie
just because it's a film doesn't mean it
isn't deeply rooted in reality
you can't judge people solely based on
where they work or how they look
you need to think hard and decide things
for yourself
fun okay i didn't expect that so allow
me to
still happen how do you feel about me i
don't know
i only just met you even half exactly
now it sounds like you're thinking you
should never feel the need to force an
answer out or pretend like you know
something
oh my god zack she's a good kid he's
[ __ ] awesome honest and
straightforward
oh wait there's one thing is it where
rice is
what when you talk to yourself like that
it really creeps me out you deserve did
you start doing that after you became an
adult
or have you just always done that by the
way you should stop doing it
it's really weird and like makes me
wince whenever i hear
it oh zach did you hear that no need to
worry
neither of us are weird i can assure you
of that she's probably just having
trouble finding the right word to
describe
yeah no i think i'll stop there wouldn't
want her to think we're getting
desperate that's
like i said it's a bit cute actually
that they did that
that's a bit cute i'm i'm into the
self-awareness of what just happened
here
she [ __ ] dunked on him for being a
weirdo
because he is um
rice hello
i can't believe i'm doing this you know
i just i could have done so many things
with my friday night
like play a different video game um
and that's about the entire list but i
have so many options for other video
games
and here i [ __ ] am in a field
just
[ __ ] just looking for ice
where is the rice if you know where it
is bizarre where is it where is the rice
i ain't [ __ ] seen [ __ ]
come got rice back here somebody had
rice out here
anybody
no there's still just no rice at all
there's just nothing
dig up the field what do you mean by
that that
that's probably wrong that's probably
not
what i'm supposed to be doing i don't
think it's digging
is the solution here
no i don't know what you're talking
about i don't know what you're talking
about
just somebody's gotta help me find this
rice man
like can somebody google it
where is the rice
i don't know what this video game wants
me to do you know i don't know what
wait what is that is that what's that
marker
what does that mean i don't remember i
feel like i should know what this means
but that i've forgotten because i
haven't played this game in almost a
month
what is this why
what
[Music]
she's gonna be more sugarcane ass
outside the bomb okay well i've been
outside the barn
whereabouts outside the barn
because i've done that i definitely done
that
by the river all right let's give it a
let's give it a look i definitely
checked all around the bottom near the
river under the bush of course
of course that's where the [ __ ] rice
is
let's just pull out my skateboard
because conveniently it works perfectly
on grass and always sounds like
it is on a road no matter what
so there's nothing to worry about
okay you're telling me there's rice like
around here maybe
is what i'm being told
rice is
why
why was it there
somebody had to make this decision
somebody had to go okay
so we're gonna have the detective walk
into the church while looking for
someone
and then he's gonna get lectured about
how he needs to find food for god
and he's gonna try and get some beans
but then when he goes to get the beans
from the location that has the beans
you're gonna tell him to find rice
the rice is going to be in the middle of
some grass
at a sugar cane plantation
how was i ever supposed to know why did
you
it's fine it's fine nope we [ __ ] we
got the rice
so she says why it was literally
oh my god okay okay
yeah no i would have found it that's it
of course it makes sense why it was
there who am i kidding
why is that this is the deep sound is it
i feel it every time that molten hot sun
deep cell check
don't use zac i know we checked this
last time um for the specific check but
uh
is that a thing can anyone from the deep
south confirm
that uh you feel the hot
molten sun pour down on you when you're
in the deep south you just gotta check
on that just
i'm gonna need just yes or no
there's no someone said it's fact
yes
it seems like it's mostly mostly the
consensus is yes
from florida okay okay got it thank you
appreciate that
all right let's keep going
oh sick basically bro that was tight
um okay let's go back to the diner
and get what is it god hungers or
whatever the lord hungers sorry
um beans for the lord
oh [ __ ] cattle that they promotion
what are you
is squirrels you trying to steal my [ __ ]
again bro i don't want anything to do
with any of you don't go on the road
oh these squirrels are going hard
okay i think the diner is the closest
thing
in any case my inventory is not an issue
so we could do these things in a
different order that's just the freedom
the daily premonition 2 offers you know
is sometimes
you go get rice and then you get spinach
rather than getting the beans
uh what's your oyster baby
do whatever you want okay beautiful
beautiful frame rate
love it you'd love to see it okay let's
i hope this works
please please the lord hungers
i just need some [ __ ] beans so i can
solve crimes just
give it five minutes it's fine just give
it a couple hours and we'll be
totally cool
that wasn't too bad
[Music]
oh the air out there don't feel right
today you feel it what does that mean
take beans
[Music]
i did i got you a single rice i don't
know they even want to cook with that
love it was [ __ ]
under a shrub
why did they do that i just don't
understand
oh man
why did they put it there like
okay okay and now i'm walking on um i'm
cutting up some of the text let me make
myself a little bit smaller
there we go i hope you'll be a dear
are you you [ __ ]
she's gonna make me
[Music]
[ __ ] me oh they're at a house maybe
that's easy maybe that'll be
[ __ ] you oh she said it would be a
little bit hard to find
oh
yeah you don't talk about films again ah
yes the cook the thief his wife and her
lover in 1989 a classic directed by
peter green away
of course that's what i that is what i'm
glad you wrote
in this video game rather than making
ingredients easy to locate
one of the few european films we ever
watched together you guys know that
so after suffering intense domestic oh
oh
um after suffering intense domestic
violence at the hands of her husband a
woman takes a lover
but her husband finds out and that seals
the lover's fate that's [ __ ] up
in order to get revenge she has a chef
cook up her dead lover's body
a bizarre murder spice with cannibalism
it's a story that could happen any day
of the week
is it
is it though
[Music]
the director must have wanted to express
realistic crime in that film
i'm not saying that that couldn't ever
happen but any day of the week
and realistic crime
god argued it was possible for the lover
to be cooked into a whole roast
jesus christ okay
you're presenting me with some
interesting questions that i've never
thought about before
can you cook an entire human into a
roast
i mean yeah i would think you can
[Music]
okay this is gonna be a [ __ ] show
let's get something else instead i would
love you know what i would [ __ ] love
to do
just go buy a can of spam
that would be great uh alex cool the
shadow band
fixed itself last time so i
imagine it'll fix itself again i also
don't care
um all right let's go see if we can get
you know what actually i would prefer to
get the thing that i can buy at azulli
fritos so let's do that first let's buy
canned spinach
and then go and do this [ __ ] fetch
quest
[ __ ] for alexis
thank you corporal banana i appreciate
that don't
wonder that ghost skill you said i
wonder what human roast tastes like
don't wonder that
don't buy into this game's shenanigans
don't think about that that's not good
dude
oh boy
let's go
i'm gonna go to azule frito i'ma get
some spinach
get spinach solve crimes that's what i
always say everyone who knows me
knows that that's my catchphrase get
spinach solve crimes i do eat a lot of
spinach
it's true yet to solve a crime
but i will um
which is where is azulee frida i don't
remember here
this is my main waypoint right now sun
again i could get the fast travel but
what if i just pulled my skateboard out
of thin air and
[ __ ] skated there
see better than the horse and ghost
sashima you run into something just
immediately turns around it's perfect
it's flawless it's the ideal video okay
all right
i think that's it right there it's
showing up probably
you know what i think that the talk
thing is an update
i think that the talk option hit uh
which i'm if i move my head down you can
see it
he used to just talk and say the same
[ __ ] over and over again every time that
he was on
the skateboard but now it's prompting
you
all right please jesus [ __ ] christ
just let me buy canned spinach in your
like magic shop
[ __ ]
god
oh thanks tx viper i appreciate that
look at all you drunk people watching
this i guess that's what happens when i
stream it
checks notes 11 p.m thank you oscar
all right see does this look like a
place that would sell canned spinach
it doesn't i wouldn't have guessed hello
mate legolas do you carry any canned
goods here
canned goods the vermin of the grocery
store
name i think i do like his chest
tattoo though that's a cool rose you
have there
the question mark on your forearm
sucks um but i'd i understood mirror
well then if you'll excuse me then why
did i come here
yes spinach spinach
i can see it i can see
the can good thou seeketh
okay how intriguing
well then where is the canned good i see
in a place where no we're just talking
about canned spinach dude
it doesn't have to be this complicated i
see
in a place where it can't be bought from
a person
got it mirror was but a trifle
for the lord i keep being told the lord
hungers yeah
i did i'd actually never heard that
before but i
zack it's in a vending machine thank you
[ __ ] me i wouldn't have guessed
it appears that god wants us to go on a
wild goose chase all around
god yeah sometimes
it do be like that with god you know
wild goose chase all around town
i think i'm gonna need your help here
chad um
because i would really prefer not
to struggle to find every single one of
these if someone could give me help
you know i'll look vaguely
but wow i would prefer
you know to not have to find [ __ ]
canned spinach
in a random vending machine
which is probably not even gonna be in
the vending machine i'll find it and
it'll be busted and it'll be under a
rock
in a garage
don't tell me yet you know i'll take a
look first i'll take a look first
come on baby what's up what's wrong
what's you ain't got that much to load
nailed it all right that was
not helpful buy canned spinach from a
vending machine
somewhere in town
it's m31
isn't it yeah so that's
not on the map i guess we just stop at
every [ __ ] vending machine so let's
try and do one of the others
we could pay a visit to chuck why is
that a main quest
oh okay okay i have to go to a wall-e
to get beyond the abandoned train and
then talk to chuck
yeah sometimes you gotta do a wall-e you
know it's just
detective life bro let's try this one
which is also not going to work but
melvin's
crawfish which is where
that's from emma's skateboard shop
um where's le crawfish bro
i don't remember uh
um
so why is it not telling me what things
are when i hover over them shouldn't be
doing that
is it on the map but i'm just not seeing
it is or is the crawfish his like little
standy thing that's next to
the police station oh thank you solid
snake
food delivery services seem like a place
they probably would have
those kinds of things um
i'm gonna try and go to the police
department
just in case that's what it wants me to
do right now let's call hot chick uber
driver
and go two the police department
it would probably actually be faster
than the loading screen if i did just
skateboard there
but you know we don't get to see this
cool car
[ __ ] yet dude you see that [ __ ] that's
the coolest thing i've ever seen
hell yeah okay
is this gonna be the place where i find
whatever the [ __ ] it is that i'm trying
to get right now okay hold on hi melvin
i love you
he just has spam
mr york that's what i needed right
you were part of me kind of i've never
had spam
no melvin i've simply gotten myself
tangled up in a little bit to be true
it'd be true oh i get it do you
mr york the lord hungers
how does everybody know yes apparently
the lord is starving
and i'm a lamb with no sense of
direction
this is so [ __ ] ridiculous
but i'm glad that you know that they all
okay
uh together on it [ __ ] hell
okay
oh thank you oscar some of you are
saying spam is good some of you saying
spam is not good
i still don't entirely know what it is
all i know is that the
lord hungers um
and that's pretty much it uh
we got the spam we need to find canned
spinach from a vending machine
somewhere in town pay visit to chuck
that's this this one
go to alexis's house
well oh i could do that too just because
it's a side quest where does alexis live
i don't feel like i know the answer to
that um
are you going to tell me where her house
is on the map maybe
mrs carpenter i think is the woman from
the bowling
abandoned factory
where the [ __ ] does alexis live bro
okay that's melvin's house
alexis and why am i going to alexis
house that doesn't make any sense
thank you nacho cheese tip i appreciate
that
that's her diner and lane there
okay let's make that the waypoint it's
gonna be that one right there let's go
let's go let's go
skateboard time
look how fast i'm going dude there are
[ __ ] wind lines
you know that means i'm speedy oh my god
it is go sushima
just [ __ ] nope okay great yep
excellent i'm trying to avoid the
squirrels because they'll steal my [ __ ]
i won't ever forget that
okay
all right bro chill out
brilliant mechanic um all right
it's gonna be her house
okay this is her house now this game has
told me anything it's that i should look
in bushes just in case
no maybe is that does that count as part
of her house or is that
pretty sick actually oh we could save
love a good phone booth yeah
yeah yeah sure why not
love a good good safe okay
anything in any of these rose bushes i'm
looking for a chili
don't worry about it this is it why
would chile not be
under a bush you know
that's a strange door placement
it's fine i'm not an engineer is it in
the couch
just another plate i guess we have to
break in
looks like a case of bad timing well
let's come back later
i mean then why couldn't she just get
the chili
why do i have to try and
i got it it was peppered it was right
there
oh so glad i looked at the [ __ ]
random seat you have
okay we have that let's try again
red beans she's gonna make me get
something else
that's all it says right now okay i'm
just gonna try
[ __ ] there's a lot of squirrels out here
man i'm getting nervous i'm sweating
this is this is intense so we're going
back to
the diner
oh that's that's choppy
i wonder if i'll ever learn to navigate
this town by memory
it's not badly laid out it's just awful
to
perceive look at that pop in look at you
go
beautiful she is gonna make me get
something else and i'm going to want to
die
but um at least i know the strat now
it is if you're looking for ingredients
they're probably outdoors um
[Music]
just sitting on a bench or
under a bush so i know now
it's like a frame an hour well that's
all i yeah
okay what are you gonna make me do next
[ __ ] i can always forget about the
goddamn loading screens
the frame rate isn't bad i don't know
what you're talking about
it's an artistic choice
just because you don't know about game
design okay
thank you ncb thank you
i appreciate that i can't kick flip
you're absolutely right
okay the air out there don't feel right
today
you feel it you said that to me last
time
yes i did get you
uh whatever it is what was it a green
something
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] what is it
time okay
my god
oh she's coming handsome
yeah true
okay great let's do it can't wait
it's going to be easy
we're waiting
it doesn't even say where this one is
[Music]
that's a bummer
that's a huge one
i got the rice though so i'm actually
gonna see if if i really can just order
this [ __ ] now because that might be a
side quest
all right oh coming right up honey i'll
put my heart and soul
uh nope i still can't get rice and beans
come back in okay you ain't gonna but it
is treating it like it's a side quest so
i'm a little bit confused
right like
[Music]
because she are these two separate
things is my question
i'm not sure
let's i [ __ ] find a vending machine i
guess while we wait on the god damn time
i don't even
know what that is
oh where that is rather i do know what
it is
the time is obtained from another quest
great of course it is
fantastic i love that for me
that's ridiculous
that's [ __ ] stupid
i love this game but that's [ __ ]
stupid chad is telling me that getting
the time is required
you have to do a mission that from avery
it's a completely different side quest
that's dub perfect video game 10 out of
10.
so what exactly is the plot here well
lone star
the lord hungers i don't know what
they're what you wouldn't understand
about that you know
the lord hungers that's it
should we look for vending machines
maybe
like i don't even know where those would
be
i do also want to just to get it off my
list
do this azulee frito
like create a voodoo charm i probably
have enough stuff to do that now
so why don't we just go do that real
quick
keep an eye out for vending machines on
the way there
just in case i can get some canned
spinach
on the way because that's what the lord
wants
you know there are a ton of vending
machines in the hotel
let's just okay i just this is just a
series of d2s
because my brain doesn't what are you
you [ __ ] staring at me you trying to
stop some [ __ ]
i'm sorry i feel bad but are you
just looking at my direction so watch
yourself
okay
i think i heard someone scream
very strange uh
okay let's give it a shot i definitely
did not get shadow band for not being
exclusive to twitch again it was for
djing for sure
all right i'm pretty sure there are
vending machines in here
spinach do you have spinach just a can
of spinach
not a single can of spinach inside is
what i was thinking
let's try somewhere else
where else are there vending machines
though you know that's the problem we
have here
i think there are just more in this
building
we just keep looking for them no
bathrooms probably don't i say with no
confidence because this game defies all
logic
could be
okay let's give it a shot
[Music]
there's one down here i'm pretty sure
yes come on spinach spinach
[Music]
this vending machine does not carry what
god seeks
yeah you're not right let's move on
you're not wrong
that vending machine does not carry
what god seeks is there another one
upstairs maybe i don't remember
let's take a quick look i feel like it's
probably not gonna be in the hotel
though
gotta find that spinach elsewhere can of
spinach sometimes you know
sometimes it do be like that
[Music]
come on well the soda it's surely not
going to be in us
not a single can let's try some [ __ ]
i'm trying somewhere else
[ __ ]
well that's gonna be it for us then
throw all the vending machines in here
are there is there one in here maybe
it's fine it's fine
i'll find it eventually um chat do not
give me tips for this please
um otherwise i won't want to read chat i
don't want to have it too spoiled unless
i like i'm asking for help if that makes
sense
we're just gonna why you look like a
cobble cutout woman
[Music]
the way that their idol is animated is
like disturbing to me
because they just sort of occasionally
flap their hands and move their heads a
tiny bit
their bodies don't move it's not good
you know something about it is not good
is what my review is going to be [ __ ]
every goddamn time
i've had uh a fair amount of um
canned spinach in my life [ __ ] off zack
b you can [ __ ] off for that comment
i read my chat a lot has nothing to do
with donations
thank you mastermind evan uh it was
our first like normal episode for the
the kind of funny axe customer
spinach artichoke dip is lit you're
absolutely right
god i haven't had food like that in so
long because i haven't eaten out at all
ordered i think i did once
really just having a lot of like fresh
produce right now it's good for you
this every time i think this is a human
with their hand up
what is this supposed to represent do
you think
okay um so that wasn't helpful we're
gonna come across this canned spinach
this requires getting time i think
because i still can't order it even
though it says
again that this is a separate it's like
a side quest that's terribly ordered
that's i don't know how i'm even gonna
do that
i don't even know how to start that um
let's do the wall-e shall we
abandoned train i think is down the
didn't mean to do that down the bottom
of the map
if i go
[Music]
i think it was like here somewhere maybe
uh i feel like it is here babyish but i
also have played this game but
it did but i feel like it was here
thompson's phone i'm not positive though
is the problem
oh this is a vending machine let's just
go there
let's just go i'm so easily distracted
let's do it good up canned spinach who
knows i don't know
i don't know why you weird dudes be put
in your canned spinach
[Music]
i should do that that holy man is the
first dp this bizarre dp is always
bizarre everyone's first dp is a wild
ride that's a euphemism
uh the first the first death of the
premonition is probably not this bizarre
though like it's still
it's still a very [ __ ] bizarre game
in terms of the characters
oh and the map i guess um
but i have to cross the river i should
have gone the other way
oh that's a tree maybe there is a bridge
closely
nope this was probably faster i'm not
entirely sure
um the characters are really bizarre but
i feel like the first one is a lot more
streamlined
than this one i'm still
unclear on the ufo height situation
some of them are too high to shoot and
then they come down i just don't really
what a lot of mystery certainly no ufos
in the first game there is a good
finishing meeting
though uh yes james they did release a
fix for the frame rate
supposedly also i don't know if it's
actually been issued yet but they
attempted to um
swear he made a statement about the
transphobia in this game
uh so maybe that's also been changed i'm
not sure if that's actually been done
yet though
i also don't really know the extent of
it all i know is that melvin said some
[ __ ] that
was just not like melvin you know
because he's a great dude
it's just he was a bit of a bomber way
point reached where is it
there's going to be a vending machine
here somewhere
i mean i mean i assume that's a vending
machine right is it gonna be like
like in this building there it is
hey bro you got any spinach though you
got any spinach
that
i feel like a god zack we finally found
our candidate
i just took a gamble you know
which is managed by clarkson food
delivery services
but who in their right mind would sell
canned goods i've never been so excited
to have canned spinach in my life
i only hope that it's not expired i feel
like that could have taken me an
absolute lifetime
or that was gonna be a thing i was gonna
ask for help on i found the [ __ ]
canned spinach dude that's sick
holy [ __ ] okay the rice was harder
because it was in a random field
um still can't do that here we go if i
can get a side quest apparently
stupid stupid okay
whoa these are two different things
maybe if i look for the shack on the map
i'll find it
thank you oscar not a lot of places to
skate in the south
really there you go
there's your uh south check
um i'm looking for a crawfish farmer
which look i understand is
pronounced uh what is it crayfish
um that's the abandoned factory
i actually think this map is pretty
pretty solid avery's house
but i don't remember where the [ __ ]
train is
it's around here somewhere right because
this is the train line so what if
i just like sort of go here i just
walk along the train line then i should
find it because that's how i came across
it last time
it was like an area of the train line
that i needed to jump something what is
that
that looks like a red tree
seems like a thing that wants my
attention
if there's anything i know about deadly
premonition
no it's totally just gonna be a tree
i haven't actually been here this is
like a beach
that's so cute
this red tree is really insignificant
somebody's been murdered here or some
[ __ ] also oh my god
this crocodile's in the water
that could that could be a bad time that
could be a bad time
i don't trust you i've played your video
game
i know your ways
somebody's buried under here
i put money on it you killed a [ __ ]
under this tree for sure
doesn't just happen for no reason in
this game i'm telling you
somebody died
okay well i wonder maybe i'm supposed to
go out there eventually
certainly not right now i don't want to
is that gator on
it looks like there's an alligator right
there what did he just do
did he just like i missed it did he sort
of jump on the spot for some reason
what where you're right there huh
yeah like just right there it's cool
i got my sweet purple gun i forgot about
mr alligator
um just trying to you know find
you know i just have to talk to the dude
who found the dead girl's body
this is the most sensible thing this
game has asked me to do in a long time
the problem is just that i don't
remember where it is
i feel like it's around here somewhere
ooh coyotes
i feel like it's it's just you know if i
just keep going along this way i
remember coming across it and being like
bro you gotta absolutely walk under that
what's your problem
this doesn't seem like the right area
though just
it doesn't feel right
but maybe that shack is is a good place
to go i don't know
i don't know is it m26 the aliens
yeah let's just do this let's head in
this direction and it should be the
right way to go
uh i'm not planning on playing grounded
on sunday scooterman giving
um i will be playing grounded for
rooster teeth tomorrow
it is also fun fact my two year
anniversary at fun house tomorrow
so um that'll be on bruceyte.com
live rt tv if you want to come out and
hang out in my anniversary stream we'll
be live from one to three i think it's
me and jacob
okay cool
hi great okay
excellent right
can i swim
no i didn't expect that you know i
didn't
was just okay how do i get there then
just gotta go around this way
i'm just gonna get to here easy we're in
the right direction
we're just naturally fbi agent terrified
of water
terrified of water it's just like
psychonauts you know sometimes your
protagonists are just terrified of water
it happens to the best of us
can't swim must do sick wall-e over
train i also don't remember how to do it
uh we're live on youtube two are just rt
i think we'll be live on fun house as
well for the first half
and then just rt uh me and jacob and
then
rihanna um who we've had as a guest on
inside gaming
i asked how to join us too i mean it's
not like it's literally an anniversary
stream for me or anything it just
happens to be
that august 8th is my two years there
[Music]
okay is this gonna work maybe could this
could this be a thing that you would let
me do
all right i didn't expect that
i think that's the thing up there that i
have to jump i don't remember how to do
it though
like triggers maybe i think maybe
yup wrong button okay this is it
because for some reason i couldn't
possibly
just walk around here and climb under
you know i just what about my suit what
if my suit got
[ __ ] what
your ass is haunted you make me
uncomfortable
that's taller than you how did you
it's fine i do like her and york is very
mean to her
and she called him a weirdo and she was
not wrong
okay i don't remember how to do a wall-e
it's fine we'll figure it out
got it we got it okay
sometimes you just got a skateboard to
solve crimes
that's what i'm saying um
not a commonly known fact don't [ __ ]
remember how to do this though
maybe like this trigger and then oh it
came up it's l
it's just l okay cool cool sweet sweet
sweet sweet
i'll sweet zl if we just do l
let's [ __ ] solve crimes
[ __ ] did i not hold it down enough
also if you did that at the speed that i
was going at and
i would just like he would have broken
his ankles or something
that would not have gone down well let's
try to try again hold it down
hold it down
[Music]
i'm pressing the right thing i don't
remember if there's a button that i'm
forgetting that should be working
you know let's just press out
is it only press l and not hold l what
other
skating mechanics we'll do until we get
it it's gonna be fine it's gonna be fine
no um
how to control find control
[Music]
quest details check out the map
journal stats and items maybe
no [ __ ] i don't remember how to
skateboard
[Music]
i've tried tapping and holding l
i remember there being something else um
i don't remember what it is i don't
remember what it is
oh no that girl is absolutely real for
the record she's not fake
[Music]
bro just jump the train
it's gonna be i'm not holding it early
enough i don't [ __ ] remember
i don't know what that means andrew but
good night
i deserve that colby you're not wrong
[Music]
these are ps1 mechanics that is also
fair that is also fair
all right try again
it even gave me the noise for pressing
it at the right time
you know i'll try holding it again maybe
i had the timing off
i don't [ __ ] know what you want me to
do deadly premonition i don't know what
you want me to do
ever about anything at any point in time
why can't i just climb under and i'll go
around it
why can't i swim
that time it didn't make the noise maybe
because i was tapping a the
[ __ ] i should have done this immediately
after the
weirdly long competitive skating
tutorial you know and i didn't think too
[Music]
wait what's that noise
oh well okay so that time i didn't press
it right and it didn't go anywhere near
as far
that might work kill chill maybe i maybe
i get off the
the board
[Music]
i'm not holding forward while i jump
tristan
uh oh the trailer ramp is there another
ramp somewhere
[Music]
it literally says it wants me to do a
wally over it it's the issue that i
don't know how to do
a wall-e and what i'm doing is not
whatever that is
no i don't this is definitely the
only option maybe the sign would be
helpful
excuse me swamp to a sign do you have
no nothing nothing the skate shop
oh hello rahul cully i could try the
skate shop
she might give me hot tips
i don't know i don't know
i'm just gonna we're gonna keep doing it
until it works
come on
that time you just didn't even [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] york
i don't why i don't remember how to find
the controls
wally is where you ride on the wall
press l at the right timing and saw i
have definitely been pressing l at the
right timing
if i have to press it while midair i
have been doing that i have been doing
that
go slower you reckon i could try go
slower
[ __ ] video game let's give it a shot
okay
this shouldn't be this hard to figure
out the spinach was so easy in
comparison
all right let's go just go nice and slow
that one was my fault i did not press l
in time
[Music]
the answer to that for the record
okay was don't accelerate
so the person who said go slower was
correct
for some reason
the solution was don't
accelerate why would you want to not
accelerate up an incline to
jump over a train carriage
[Music]
you know
again i never would have guessed
i literally never would have guessed how
would anyone have
ever guessed
[Music]
oh my god uh amish offline every single
time that i stream on youtube i also
stream on twitch i am on twitch right
now
every time
[Music]
all right let's go um i do do twitch
exclusive streams i never do youtube
exclusive streams so i guess my djing
will be
oh coyotes hello i do not want any
quarrel with you sirs
i am just trying to go meet the man
who don't come steal my [ __ ] no stop it
stop it stop it no no
[ __ ] i can't go where i'm going
i'm just trying to find the man with the
body you know who found the body that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] there's a lot of coyotes
why you go what are you all doing out
here are there this many coyotes in the
south
is that what's happened all right well
evaded them so
i guess accelerating sometimes is good
sick farm
dude hell yeah you got like so much
water in this farm
um yes the man of adamantium thank you
for asking this is the new tony hawk
um as it turns out if you would like to
jump something of significant height
you should not accelerate so
that's the thing that i want you to know
tony hawk like always fails on those
physics are you sure you really want to
talk to this guy
yeah what's wrong with him he kind of
scares me
but what's wrong with patty there's no
need for
i feel like she should have told me more
than that what specifically is scary
about him
good pan good pan chuck thompson
you were the first person to find lisa's
body correct
did you play him bud i'm fbi special
agent francis york morgan
please call me york that's what everyone
uh agent york seems like he ain't in the
mood for time
is it just me or is her forearm really
long oh
all right chuck thompson
oh he's cleaning something i have a word
with you i'm looking for the one who
fired the pistol at heaven
oh you triggered him
was it you you're trying to say i gotta
aim up to shoot cause of my height
hmm
not at all i was merely quoting the
skeletal gentleman's own
skeletal gentlemen you ain't making a
liquor sense
what do you all want anyway what do
y'all come here to raise my price i mean
it's like a pus
running a race around a reasonable
question i have to ask who fired the
starting shot
the murderer and i are competing to see
who can cross the finish line murder is
already dead
unfortunately the murderer got a
generous she's literally dead we saw her
dude
gets away from me i'll lose but if i can
catch up to him
then i'm sure i'll win what
are you talking about a trans woman i'm
confused now
who is th how do you know more about who
the motor is than i am what
what so please chuck tell me how did you
find lisa's body
he's so sexy you know if there's
anything her body was hidden
under a bridge on the board we can all
agree on it's just very close to the
mystery
morgan sex symbol it's a cigarette like
this a few miles away
from your farm in this swamp right
beautiful
wow the clarkson's all the folks who
gave me the damn permission to find
crawdad is here in the first place
now why the hell would i ever want to
kill that little girl
it's i feel like there's something up
with exactly doing out there
also yes this game did come out this
year right it absolutely did
boat around these parts ain't too big
probably only holds five or six it's got
a deep draft sick
oh [ __ ] think they can just drive
right through my turf right through my
damn crawdad form
so you gave chase which led you to
russia
yeah that's right [ __ ] cultures
oh my god he's so angry where did the
poachers go
oh hell if i know [ __ ] was thick that
day thicker than usual
so i lose sight of them the next thing i
know i'm under that goddamn oh your
goddamn crawdad and i felt a chill run
up my spine
and i knew so i drove up to the bank and
got out what is
something is wrong with his accent right
strung up on it right
altar
i love his hair though did you know
elise personally
yeah i knew her a little she never
showed me no disrespect
unlike arrested oh my god one of the
clarkson's got his arm bit off by a
crocodile and i can smell it from here
same with the [ __ ] at the bottom of this
here wow
nice
[Music]
yeah i don't find this man scary it was
a little better when their boy lenny was
still around
bunny yeah leonard
pj's he left i remember correctly
he never showed me no disrespect me
that's good
and he's the one who gave me permission
to form here
okay cool happy for you why is this
relevant to the dead woman's body
well ever since he left home it's a
southern hobbit
accent and that he would i guess it's
like sort of mixed with it
a little bit of british she was wise
because everything in every fantasy game
is british
ain't right i'll tell you
i just feel like he's not fully from the
south i don't buy it
now i'm done talking god damn it now go
on get the hell okay chuck i love you
also you are
right off to melvin phillip mentioned my
second favorite
son leaving home that must be lenny
did you know about that patty everyone
in town knows about it just ask me
by the way zach do you remember what we
saw when we were skipping stones
that boat with the dragons
zack no matter where we go in this town
we're constantly assaulted by
information related to the clarkson
family
just where is that because i haven't
touched the controller in so long
because it's a cut scene
the the game decided is that i hope that
that's not the game decided and it's
instead that the switch decided
to make the screen go dark that's
ridiculous
we successfully found the one who fired
the pistol at him all right patty jesus
chill out oh my god now we need to visit
the white hall of beds
that's the church you know zach
it almost feels like we're orienteering
here doesn't it remind you of our
training in quantico
not sure what you're referring to that's
it okay cool
oh all right great let's activate this
yep cool cool cool cool cool just in
case we need to somehow get a vehicle
here
we can what's this that big
pile of [ __ ]
um we love we love a good stone skin
yeah dude let's [ __ ] do it i don't
know how to do it though it's it's just
tap a
i think
well that was a bad one that wasn't my
fault you know that you
your stone sucked or whatever let's do
it again
this game has the best mini games of any
game i've ever played so
you're dying crawdad farm
[ __ ] you i disagree
okay just one more it's fine don't worry
about it it's fine oh this doesn't look
like a good stone
we'll take it a 10 feels good a 10 feels
good
i like it good
stuff perfect video game um
i'm just gonna like take a look at some
of his [ __ ]
i guess and then we'll go back to
the hall of the white beds aka the
church
a good question taco cub everyone in the
fbi is down to stoneskip it's very true
oh this is for nighttime activities
this is quest tings
[ __ ] dark souls rip off
garbage what's this
oh an alligator gar tail of course
it's my favorite okay
can i get on the boat that will be tight
i can go in his house yeah i'm just
gonna look around we'll see what's up in
this
in this area and then we'll go back to
the church because the lord
continues to hunger
and then i got to do that goddamn side
quests cool great love that
excellent good information good stuff
i have not played the new paper mario
yet k
y ellie um
damn it's quite a you tell me he's not
home
looks like a case of bad does it though
because let's come back he's literally
right there
like it's fine
um no i haven't played it i feel like
i'll probably get around to it
eventually i just have so many games to
play right now
i'm just gonna remove my webcam again
for you guys there you go
look at it [ __ ]
[Music]
hell yeah am i doing this for work no
eddie of course not
why does it seem like it's a bad game
that someone would not just play for fun
no this is definitely not related to
work um okay
let's all go
i don't know what's gonna happen last
time i walked in here i expected
normalcy i don't know why i expected
that from a church and didn't get
anything like
normalcy whatsoever this isn't related
to boredom what's wrong with you people
this game is super fun to play
it's just [ __ ] ridiculous but it's
very fun
i'm definitely playing it by excited
choice
you know like
garbage can be fun
uh okay you said you wanted me to come
here i think that the script was wrong i
think that it actually probably just exp
who's playing the music
um i think that it actually probably
just expected me
not to be i don't think i'm supposed to
be here right now i think that dialogue
was incorrect
yeah no we gotta get the [ __ ] red
beans and rice
which i need the time for which i don't
know where to get
[Music]
dialogue lied to me i'm not supposed to
be in the church doesn't it look like a
church
[ __ ] what kind of church is you how
does this not look like a church
[Music]
i mean you know
pretty sure it does it's just also a
hospital for the record
um they made it both i suppose which is
why this part looks like a hospital
definitely a church okay let's [ __ ]
my current objective
i'm still unclear as to
if if this the time thing is a side
quest or a main quest
because it is listed under side quests
you know so i just don't know
but the i haven't been able to order the
the red beans and rice any time i've
been
to the diner so i feel like it's just
ordering the quest
strangely and i do need to get the time
somewhere from somehow oh the time is
a side quest well then why can't i order
the
all right hotel park down
then why can't i order the whenever i go
there
and thank you oscar games like this in
rider hell retribution are some primo
forms of great game garbage i mean i
also agree that ride to hell retribution
is really fun but i don't think it's
as fun as deadly premonition
oh no i don't need to do that
okay if it's just a side quest because
it does look like it's just a side quest
then i'll just go back to the diner and
lane
again and try to get the food
somehow hang on just let me let me get
we gotta get rid of myself it's
important
there we go
[Music]
you guys can't see it but i'm dancing
you know the whole time the whole time i
dance
um when the car is up it's just good
content it's just good content
okay is it even on the menu
can i look at your menu alas i cannot is
there something else
it tells me how to get these this
goddamn
zack it appears to be closed okay let's
go sleep
let's come back okay everything else is
done unless i try and
eliminate zero the killer bees find the
doll
these are all too vague i can't still do
that one let's go to azulli frida first
because i think that's still open what
are your hours
julie frieda 24 hour
let's go let's do that and then we'll go
to the hotel and we'll take a nap
then we'll figure out how to get the
goddamn meal that i need
for the stupid goddamn
information
just for just ridiculous i'm just trying
to solve the moto you know
which i oh i'm pretty sure i already
solved which is why it's so confusing
we literally saw her do it the game's
called deadly prohibition i had one
but i don't know york has decided that
somebody else orchestrated it
so we're trying to figure that out i
guess
by doing this just all of this
all right i like the way he gets off the
skateboard though that is some cool kind
of [ __ ]
okay let's let's go let's go let's get
this
voodoo charm or whatever why is the
frame rate like this what do you mean
justice douglas
what do you mean
i too miss chuck already i ask
i don't understand what your problem
with the frame rate is everyone it's
it's perfect i don't
like to see you make a video game all
right it's literally flawless
okay hey dude
thou art a seeker
i didn't expect that yes
talk all items in our world can't
be split into two categories the
valuable and that which lacks value
could have said invaluable
wait no invaluable would mean still very
valuable or maybe it means both it could
be synonymous
i am a special human with the power to
discern such
among these items once joined the five
colored beads values shall
rise beyond any dream five colored beads
first the blue bead its name ocean nay
the deep ocean bead
sometimes i just had to take a break to
just you know process it okay as blue as
the deep blue sea itself
that's just the first one second the red
bead its name
blood nay the saints blood bead a bead
is crimson as the blood of a proud saint
i mean yeah you basically spelled that
out
third the green bead it's named summer
nay indeed its name is
forest neymar nay nay so what's the name
of the green bead
tis tis known as the young leaf bead
incredible incr
ground breaking dialogue why didn't you
record vo for this this is gripping
[ __ ] yes the young leaf bead as green as
new budding leaves
next comes white white the fresh snow
bead as white and pure as a virgin
i feel about that and when all beads are
joined
you've only listed four so far what
there are five special beads in total
right
four sooth there are five
[Music]
this game just really happens to you you
know sometimes it just
[ __ ] it just comes to you and it just
happens
okay you only listed four deep ocean
beats saints blood b
young leaf bead and fresh snow beat
didst i not also list
the abyssal by
a bead so black it could suck away every
last
ray of light never heard of it before
neither me nor zack
thou shall gather all five coloured
beads gather
me well i mean we've been doing that for
a while from york
forsooth is forsooth a word
could somebody check that for me as
forsooth a real word
thou art a human who perceiveth the true
value art thou not
no meaning
i bestowed thee with knowledge of the
five colored beads
now only thou can determine thy next
action zack you seem to believe these
five color beads are special
forsooth is a word
it is great
uh you know what i'm going to say i'll
always agree with your opinion
great so you instead of
me finishing the one quest that i wanted
to finish you just gave me another
fine [ __ ] quest this is what i was
trying to do i'm trying to create a
voodoo challenge
oh can i afford any of these yet that
was the issue before right there are
like [ __ ] skateboarding charms and
stuff
okay it has to be a necklace
does it i still can't afford any of it
we need a lot of cloth i guess
nope cool just got another side quest
thy return is thou have discovered the
very purpose of my
emporium that is
absolutely not i came to you for canned
spinach
so like not even a little bit
do i understand the purpose of whatever
is happening here
very nice tristan very nice
correct yes all of the actual important
uh
lines of dialogue are voice acted side
content isn't which i'm cool with
it's a smart way to balance it because
they still put just as much personality
in the stuff that isn't voice acted
this game is not well sorry this game is
not badly written
it's just bizarre it's not the writing
is not bad the characters are
like solid um and consistent it's just
very strange hotel is this way
it is look look at me learning wait am i
or is it not am i absolutely facing the
wrong way
i totally am it's definitely this way
that's a bummer
i'm so proud of myself
is that it there am i yes okay
four p.m time to go to bed because
there's nothing else to do today
apparently better take a nap
bro my skateboard's breaking
okay all right see ya everyone hi
guy on chat hey good to see you
how you doing
oh hell yeah i've just got so much money
for traveling over 25
miles i wish that happened in the real
world he gets paid a lot
was it 420 did i just miss that it was
420 rtx
ah blaze it dude what happened to the
cars in this town
i don't know something about the south
probably it's like too hot or whatever
because of
the south i don't know
i don't pretend it makes any sense
um all right go take us
just have a nice sleep
because
you know i think it's actually
downstairs
it is um because i don't have anything
else to do today that sounds at all
interesting
finding beads
not really what i wanted to do with my
time
the sun melted the cars exactly exactly
skateboarding only
cars too hot this everyone who's from
the south knows this i don't know why
you guys need me to tell you
confirm deep south law equals cars don't
work in the sun
exactly thank you you get it everyone
knows that uh no we want to sleep for
ages like a really long time because
if you're awake at the bad hours
the the those dudes with the scissors
appear
which really did shake me the first time
i saw them i really came out of nowhere
good stretch bro good stretch
[Music]
all right um oh uh
food you're starving dude
you are starving just go upstairs
get your ass a nice meal that's what
happens when you sleep for
how long do i make him sleep for 14
hours or whatever
let's do it
yup all right
let's let's go food please
and that's what i'm talking about the
bell
all right you can't get fine eaten like
this at any of those
diamonds so make sure you enjoy it take
that alexis or whatever
um
let's go with the seafood platter just
[ __ ] around and get seafood for dinner
thank you oscar
you saying the game's 18 hours
thank you colby i appreciate you
sticking up for it you're right this
game has no frame rate issues
thanks mister those don't exist that's
what is the frame rates have made up
term it's not real you're just you're
just making up
[ __ ] to next time talk about this video
game
and i i don't appreciate it uh check
your bias at the door all right
how did i lose hp
never mind video game is perfect and i
resent anyone who tries to tell me that
this frame rate and the fact that this
keeps happening
is a flaw you just don't know fine art
okay
oh the longest you've slept is 18 hours
yeah i slept for 19 months i think
exactly everyone who's trying to tell me
this game has issues is gaslighting i
100 agree uh yes justice
it is a switch exclusive again
just in case anyone wasn't aware this
game came out
this year this i'm not playing a retro
game
i'm not like playing a ps1 remaster for
fun
this game out this game out this game
came out in 2020 just let that sit
just just think about it you know just
let that
marinate on your body and just enjoy it
do with that what you will that's all
i'm saying
not pushing you but it's [ __ ] game of
the year that's what i'm trying to say
[ __ ] game of the year
okay we're gonna just try the diner
again because it's some [ __ ] point
i'm gonna get this quest objective
call wyven i do love her it's so close
though
it's a waste of money i shouldn't do it
look a vehicle
hold up that car just [ __ ]
cleaned me and i got pedestrian damages
you charged me
that was really [ __ ]
it's really rude can you imagine being
run over and then being charged for
damaging a car
to be fair i was standing in the middle
of the road i will give
a bath
you guys are going to have a fight
because that's what it looks like
are you rolling out here what are you
some kind of baseball oh she's a bowler
cute dress i would wear that
all right this is you guys having a good
chat like riveting conversation or
what are you what are you guys talking
about
weather huh it's crazy out here in the
south it sucks that the cars don't
wow speaking of cars that's a statement
is this one of yours it's a nice ride
how do you feel about
america you um you a fan
of of the united states i don't think
you have enough stars though
so you might want to address that but uh
otherwise
is this a hearse do you rent this out
for funerals maybe
is that just like very specific kinds of
families use this
for their funerals um
all right well it was nice chatting to
you guys um i'm gonna see if i can get
some
[ __ ] beans
a very patriotic death you're absolutely
right okay once [ __ ] beans alexis i
swear to [ __ ] god
i just i'm i'm
you know you know thank you jonty
thank you very much it has to be an 80s
movies reference though
you know
i'm starting to just even based on
someone just said
uh no beans for me today i'm starting to
suspect
that the beans are timed
the air out there don't feel say enough
for so long alexis say something else
um x
oh coming right up what was so funny
i'll put my heart and
okay into it okay
this is the same as it has been every
other day though how the [ __ ] do i get
the beans
come back anytime you ain't gonna it's
been the same
every other day you have the quest
[ __ ] thing on you
is it if it's just talk then it does the
side quest [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you in your time
[Music]
do you think i'm sunburned enough to get
this this this
whatever the [ __ ] this is this hot cream
for hot dudes
that gives me abs
[Music]
i'll get sunburned one day and you'll
see that because it kind of looks like
him right
like we you know like if york was
shredded
and sunburned that would basically be
it um all right i don't know how to do
this quest
can you help me you sir do you have any
tips
if i have to like get to a different day
then it should at least
say in here somewhere that there is a
certain day
at which this serves the particular meal
that i want
otherwise i'm gonna burn the whole
[ __ ] thing down
ah
he could have abs i don't know that he's
that kind of dude though i feel he
probably
isn't that kind of dude i don't know
i think it's monday's jose that they
have beans here
someone said beans only on monday
all right [ __ ] what so i just have to
sleep for like a year
have i tried the avengers beta i
actually did try
um but i've had uh i tried this
afternoon but i had major um connection
issues i was going to stream it with
lawrence but couldn't um
i'll maybe try again tomorrow i
definitely want to play it for sure
oh the side quest dialogue is blocking
the part when she tells you it's on
mondays brilliant
10 out of 10 video game
uh okay
i think the only way to do this is to
sleep
if i have to go from thursday to monday
i think can i sleep for several days or
will i stop to death
i'm asking about real life not the video
game just curious does anyone know
if i try to sleep for the next four days
straight will i start today because i
would like to
get off stop put your hand down it every
time
all right let's see what [ __ ] happens
i'm trusting you chat that it's monday
i don't want to go get the time because
i don't know where it is
you know just
i'll need water though that's true you
actually wouldn't
in real life die if you um
didn't eat for four days i think you can
go three days without water
i'm not sure
can't die if i'm asleep that's what i
always say all right
let's [ __ ] try and sleep until monday
francis york morgan party animal
let's do it let me still don't know why
that's there
with the faces and everything what
it's fine okay i would like to wake up
in [ __ ]
[Music]
damn it of course
well we're just gonna try to sleep for
24 hours over and over again oh wow i'm
i am i have body odor
what i didn't know that was a mechanic
look i have flies look at these new
friends
what
wow emergent gameplay
it's so dynamic i will take a shower and
then we'll eat and then we'll sleep for
another 24 hours
this is what you came to see right this
is what you wanted me to stream this is
the content that you were after right
right it's gonna be great
what oh he's talking about psycho
i did see that i did see that i just
want you to take a shower though because
you stink
but i missed it because i was looking at
the chat
death ship have not seen it 1980
directed by alvin rakoff
yeah of course the script concerned is a
nazi torture ship that turned
why do you do this it's fine a nazi
torture ship that turned into a ghost
ship
ever wandering the sea and searching for
new blood
what's a nazi torture ship
is that a place where they experimented
that turned into a ghost ship does that
mean
that it is a ghost nazi torture boat
because that sounds like the worst thing
i've ever heard of
i don't know how you get worse than a
naughty torture ghost boat
that seems like a bad idea an extremely
believable scenario
sarcasm okay little sass mouth my toes
call it how realistic that film was are
you
are you being serious i don't know that
he has a sense of humor
a somber atmosphere with heavy duty
acting from a truly talented cast easily
a masterpiece of a film see now i think
he's being serious
and the scene where the shower squatted
out blood was so beautiful that i'm
pretty sure i was blinded for a moment
i would never want to bathe in blood
shower myself that's good to know
i'm glad to hear that about you oh okay
shower's broken
let's go ask the concierge to fix it
inspect the water valve and cast a
pineapple to
okay great shower cool
first i should probably eat it's fine
we'll get it done
run away i gotta check how long i'm
streaming for i'm trying to not stream
for more than two hours because
then youtube [ __ ] the streams up and
we're at
1 50 so i got like five minutes before i
got to cut it off so youtube doesn't
destroy the stream
so let's go eat and then fix the shower
eating is up
and then i'll probably have to stop and
we will have to
you know sleep for 24 hours in a goddamn
row next time
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about i am pst
how am i alive what do you mean
every time that i stream on a weekend
and people are like it's so
late i'm like it's it's literally
12 it's midnight what do you mean
it's not that it's not not a late time
for a weekend you know
what are you people doing on friday
nights you know
it's at 110 minutes i mean it definitely
says to me that it's at
an hour and 50. thanks mister
so um i've been djing
next time you get seven years i believe
it's six or seven
all right
we'll go try to fix the shower to get
rid of these flies
to be fair if you slept for 24 hours you
probably would stink
that's not the concierge this is that's
fine
hey bell boy what's this balloon doing
here
oh hey there boss that balloon belongs
to the transportation
service transportation zach we haven't
seen a single taxi
why are you introducing this mechanic
now
we've been using the taxi services whole
time well of course not
you won't find a single limo or taxi
driving around this yeah it's like uber
what does the balloon call then that'd
be why
burn wyvern that pushy entrepreneur
right on the money boss wyven is
actually a type of like dragon in it
why are you helping her out me oh i'm
just in it
boy is a concealer right here costs more
than i'm calling her from
somewhere else exactly although there
are
certain places that you can only get to
from
oh that's interesting i see zach it
looks like we've run into yet another
uni
can anyone confirm for me is this a
unique rural custom
um i don't know how to phrase to you
what question i'm asking i just want you
to answer
yes or no
um because that's what he's saying so
yes cool thank you rural custom
confirmed whatever this is what is the
the loading screen for i didn't do
i didn't do anything i just tried to
speak to the man to get my shower fixed
what are you
why you don't i just don't
i didn't what this i can't [ __ ] know
i don't know what's happening
oh my god
[Music]
still just you know i'm still loading
it's cool
how's the investigation coming must be
going okay if you're on the cake
appreciate that um
okay i didn't want any of this thanks
for coming i didn't
quite the new cutting edge
transportation listen i'm just trying to
get my shoulders
wherever you are just give up try and
fix my shower
[ __ ] hell
okay cool let's try that again i guess
jesus christ okay okay
just [ __ ] give it a shot shall we
it's a garbage [ __ ]
[Music]
um maybe bellboy isn't the right call
like
is this what you consider a concierge
because i would consider this a
receptionist
but you know what do i know
we always strive to provide our guest
with the cool fix my shower [ __ ]
our humble bucolic town does have its
inconveniences
shopping in particular can be a bit of a
slog
you're not wrong therefore we decided to
provide a modest selection of daily
necessities right here at our very own
cool is one of those a
shower fixer sounds convenient exactly
no no none of them are
first aid kits cup of coffee cola root
beer feather cigarette middle cigarette
heavy cigarette lollipop butter cookie
oh yeah i forgot that if i maybe i
should buy a bunch of cigarettes because
that pauses time
yeah yeah
okay did i have to buy something to fix
the shower is that what i missed
sleeping bags oh that's neat
you can sleep outside adhesive cleaner
oh well okay let's do that
can clean you up a great deal the duster
would probably work better i suppose
i still would like to fix my shower
though please don't would you mind if i
asked you just
one question by all means please ask me
whatever you like sir do you run this
entire hotel
all on your own i mean just oh yeah by
the way
york's theory is that um the same dude
is the chef the concierge and the bell
boy
yes that is correct sir so you
or the three of you own the entire place
oh heavens no sir the chef the bell boy
and myself are all mere but he's pretty
sure they're all the same person
so the clarkson's owned this place
it's like you're new here
[Music]
not quite not quite the next time
someone says something that's not
entirely accurate i'm gonna be like
that is incorrect
no this hotel
opened its doors long before the
clocksons came together got it
impressive did you fix my shower no
wonder this building has such a
dignified air too
indeed this is probably the only
building in all of lucari that has
managed to retain its original
appearance
so who's the owner i simply must know
the name of the person who had the
fortune and sense to come into
possession of such a fight and also
are they capable of fixing showers
the owner of this hotel is none other
than
david jawarra that's you zach
that's the fourth oh okay so he is four
people
it all makes sense now it would be
stranger if only the owners
it's got like four personalities it's
chill don't worry about it don't
question it it's
how this video game works so i sincerely
hope i get a chance to meet him during
my stay here
if i may mr morgan said why not just
trying to
unfortunately our owner has a bit of a
personality that's
i'm noticing that the three of us here
describe him as having a
i'm into this subplot okay
so you fix my [ __ ] shower very good
please
[ __ ] serving you please do let me [ __ ]
we're out of time i have to cut the
stream but i never found a way to shower
and it's just
devastating thank you all for watching
i'll try to
do the stream again uh sometime
in less of a span from the last one
because you guys got to find out what
happens next time i get it
on this